[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un pense bête pour annoncer l'ouverture
du pass culture aux 15 17 ans à côté
d'une pile de livres les mémoires de de
gaulle et un tome du manga one piece
sans oublier la montre lip tricolore
rien n'a été laissé au hasard dans cette
photo publiée sur les comptes en ligne
des manuels macron la mise en scène
inspire des internautes critique
vis-à-vis du président et de son bilan
vers les sans abri d'autres sortent leur
collection de picsou magazine ou les
seins mots pour ne pas oublier de vider
le lave-vaisselle ou de sortir les
poubelles
marine le pen rassemblement national qui
fait son post it aussi alors ses écrits
petit s'écrit faire des jeunes la
priorité du quinquennat avec le
programme jeunes à droite et puis à
gauche à un livre sur l'enfance
maltraitée
eric zemmour par égalera c'est pas un
post-it ils se sont dit un nom résume
pas la politique d'eric zemmour avec un
post-it là vous avez tout le programme
d'eric zemmour si vous voulez résumer en
une dizaine de post it et notamment
arrêter d'emmerder les français et voilà
vous l'avez sept premiers jours de mois
apportent des changements dans notre
quotidien d'abord ce coup dur pour pour
le portefeuille l'électricité ou voit
son prix augmenter de 4% vous le voyez
ici à l'écran autre changement qui
risque de faire mal aux automobilistes
les tarifs sur les principaux réseaux
d'autoroutes de france qui vont
augmenter de 2% en moyenne et ça c'est
dès ce matin bloomberg a fait ses petits
calculs sur la base des prévisions des
analystes financiers et elle prédit que
les profits cumulés par les entreprises
du cac 40 devraient excéder les 137
milliards beaucoup d'euros c'est du
jamais vu dans l'histoire de l'indicé
vedette de la bourse de paris alors
aujourd'hui on pourrait se dire que les
choses ont changé eh bien pas du tout
quand les députés de la france un saut
miss fraîchement élu débarque au palais
bourbon sans cravate c'est un acte de
résistance
revendiquait par jean luc mélenchon il y
a eu dans cette assemblée des sans
culottes il y a dorénavant des cent
cravates dans cette station service
d'issy les moulineaux les prix du
carburant continuent de s'envoler on est
obligé chercher les pompes les moins
chers dans la région on le ressent bien
sûr au quotidien ses serres ça aura un
impact sur notre pouvoir d'achat c'est
une évidence en hausse depuis plusieurs
semaines les prix atteignent désormais
des records en sept jours le prix du
litre a augmenté d'un point 64 centimes
pour atteindre 1 euros 67 en moyenne et
dans l'imaginaire de la gauche le peuple
ne porte pas de cravate c'est la
référence des gens de pouvoir et même un
déplacement symbolique du ps à la
compositrice annoncé l'anthropologue
anarchiste d'avenir est belle la flèche
vers le bas pour lui c'est symbole de la
domination me masoud olaf l'acidité
c'est comme on veut voir deux fois on
introduit donc le concombre même s'il
est légèrement courbé dans l'étui puis
en grandissant il a donc occupé tout le
volume et or se redresser pour donner et
bien sûr légumes tout droit tout ça pour
faire plaisir aux humains
oui oui enfin tout cas la reine surtout
la reine victoria qui était très à
cheval sur leur bon droit
et puis il ya un autre chiffre
astronomique même édifiant plus de 2000
milliards de dollars quasiment 1900
milliards d'euros c'est le pib de
l'italie et c'est le montant que les
entreprises devraient verser à leurs
actionnaires
dans le monde entier cette année qui
donc alimenter ce sentiment dans
l'opinion que la puissance financière
n'a pas que du mépris pour la réalité
sociale
tu veut plus la voir ta maison
tu veux la faire s'il veut faire plaisir
à sa famille
ça c'est pour ta baignoire
tonight tonight
dans une optique mike karz dans les
entrailles l'assemblée nationale
j'ai la réponse et chamailleries non
mais c'est view
pas dire un mot sans être entré six
loups dit tahmina
vous en mêlez pas
se rejoignaient là c'est aujourd'hui à
la maîtresse d'école ici moins jusqu'à
ce météo pas moi ça me fatigue elle a un
peu raison parce que c'est parce que si
en guest et pour qu'on puisse pouvoir
discuter les filins vrai on a fait je le
dis c'est pas moi j'avais même si on
vient c'est aussi pouvoir échanger
qu'est-ce que a dit à votre épouse ce
monsieur alors on n'était pas là ça
c'est vous qui le dit mais qu'est ce qui
lui aurait dit et ben en fait il nous a
simplement dit d'aller
chez julien courbet à j'avais pas sa
bonne foi
vous êtes surpris c'est selon la
mairie pas péter kent a voilà put1 voilà
ça y est c'est très chic et la
plantation professionnelle continue à
les faire la paix ut eu chez monsieur
courbes et oui en 2022 il est établi que
chacun est libre de son corps est porté
par de nombreuses figures féminines les
poils ne sont plus vraiment tabou chez
les femmes
tout le monde ne semble pas vraiment
prêts à accepter cette transformation
comme l'histoire de cette tique tokyo
américaine qui a cru bon d'envoyer une
photo de ses jambes poilues à son mec
il a aussi tout larguer moi je me
démaquille sur les réseaux en filmant
pour montrer du côté naturel je me
montre en train de faire du sport est en
train de transpirer parce que c'est mon
quotidien vous transpirez
et apparemment sans soucis de santé
selon certains médias ce qui m'a fait
beaucoup rire ah oui mais mais voilà là
j'ai quelques remarques à faire sur le
choix de la peinture
les tâches la hausse et quoi là c'est
quand vous avez plus de papier wc ah non
non non christophe a voulu faire un test
de couleur pour voir que par rapport au
plafond pour faire la même couleur la
petite centaine de cochons fait presque
partie de la famille du coup on a de la
chance
mais la vendre
ça marche pas toujours
aller en chaleur donc elle se laisse
grimper comme si c'était le verra il à
180 en disant voilà on n'évacue pas le
plus vieux du cette tortue vous l'aimez
julliard d'un je disais qu'il refusait
non c'est vrai que bon
cent quatre-vingt dix ans est fou c'est
quand même beaucoup il a élu domicile 1
sur l'île de sainte hélène dans l'acte
et l'atlantique sud et jonathan donc a
perdu la vue et l'odorat m'est pas la
libido parce qu'ils ne voient
régulièrement s'affubler avec quelques
partenaires 1 199
c'est énorme elle était comment cette
cuisine avant tegenbos
mon fils il pouvait jouer avec du boudin
que je vais connaître jouer
effectivement les usages rajeunissent
des enfants aujourd'hui un enfant sur
deux en primaire est déjà sur un réseau
social et on ne sait pas forcément mais
oui et on ne sait pas forcément à 82 en
asie où il a déjà au moins un compte sur
un réseau social tik tok en particulier
merci beaucoup aux beaucoup à cette
affaire beaucoup pas